[Musica]
buonasera sta andando questo non dando
non vi nascondo che quando sono stato
chiamato per venire qui oggi
naturalmente è un grandissimo piacere
scintilla mi hanno detto subito era la
cosa di cui avrei dovuto parlare insomma
son trovato un po spaesato perché
partire a raccontare della complessità
delle cose di cui vi voglio parlare
partendo dalla scintilla mi sembrava una
sfida abbastanza complicata e proprio
per questo ho deciso di accettarla e ha
cominciato a pensare cosa vuol dire
scintilla cosa mi veniva in mente allora
da fisico varie scintille varie metafore
vari e significati che questa cosa porta
con sé questa parola porta con sé
ho pensato a la scarica elettrica che
una uno degli argomenti che ho studiato
che ci insegnano e la prima cosa che mi
è venuta in mente
immaginate di avere un circuito quindi
avete due parti di questo circuito che
sono la differenza di potenziale se sono
staccate non passa corrente quando lo
chiudete invece cerchio si chiude si
accendono le lampadine che succede
mentre però lo state per chiudere quando
i conduttori sono ancora distanti fra di
loro
a un certo punto c'è una scintilla c'è
un passaggio prima che si tocchino e
l'isolante il di elettrico che c'è e
mezzo si rompe ora io sono sicuro che
non avete capito nulla di quello che ho
detto è colpa mia
allora passiamo a una cosa che invece è
esattamente quello che succede quando
l'atmosfera e la superficie terrestre
diventano sufficientemente cariche
vediamo questi fenomeni bellissimi
queste scarichi che abbiamo e quando
abbiamo capito che la scintilla in
questo senso non è niente altro con
passaggio un ponte fra due cose che sono
opposte che sono differenti allora noi
di questo fenomeno possiamo cominciare
per esempio a sfruttarlo perché quello
che succede quando nei nostri motori
quando andiamo nelle automobili
vogliamo incendi
la miscela di aria e benzina quindi
abbiamo le candele che servono proprio a
questo lo possiamo anche utilizzare per
l'arte ci sono tantissimi video su
youtube e voglio ripetere quello che c'è
scritto non provate a farlo a casa
perché abbastanza pericoloso potete
riprodurre queste figure bellissime
queste scariche anche sopra la
superficie come in legno che noi non
associamo di solito alla conduzione di
energia elettrica
allora da qui sono partito questo era
uno dei primi significati ce ne sono
altri che mi sono venuti in mente però
pensavo per la storia che vi voglio
raccontare che questo fosse
assolutamente del punto di partenza la
scintilla quindi come metafora come
metafora del passaggio del passaggio di
conoscenze da una da un nodo ad un altro
nodo da un conduttore un altro all'altra
parte del conduttore del circuito e
anche in qualche modo la scintilla viene
utilizzato come metafora per l'inizio di
un cambiamento
la scintilla che ha dato fuoco a un
cambiamento di idee la scintilla che ha
originato una rivoluzione è che essendo
un fisico che studia la complessità mi
piacerebbe che questa metafora si
applicasse anche alle cose che studio
ora qual è la rivoluzione di che cosa
stiamo parlando perché la scienza della
complessità può essere utile in questo
periodo in questo momento perché il
mondo intorno a noi è cambiato il mondo
in cui noi stiamo vivendo è radicalmente
differente dal mondo in cui sono vissuti
i nostri genitori
i nostri progenitori noi viviamo in
quello che si chiama un diluvio di dati
quindi abbiamo una serie di dati che ci
circonda vedo moltissimi giovani non
devo spiegarvi che cosa sono i social
che cosa è internet però pensate ad
alcune misure non le diciamo tutte però
immaginati che ogni secondo ci sono 2
milioni e mezzo di mail
vengono scambiate su internet ogni
minuto ci sono 300 ore di filmati che
vanno su youtube
quindi ogni anno noi produciamo una
quantità di informazioni ci sono varie
stime ma è pari a tutta la quantità di
informazione prodotta dall origine
dell'umanità fino all'anno scorso
quindi noi ogni anno raddoppiamo la
quantità di informazione ora
naturalmente questi dati sembrerebbero
poterci dire tutto sul mondo che
conosciamo mai dati se uno non li sa
interpretare non riesce a sfruttarli
allora che cosa si può fare per chi
serve questa scienza della complessità
serve appunto per estrarre informazione
da questi dati
questo non è una pratica nuova una
pratica realtà abbastanza antica nel
senso che anche nella storia
dell'umanità e nella storia della
scienza delle persone hanno provato
diciamo a seguire delle strade e senza
magari avere avere i mezzi tecnici per
spiegarle il faccione sempre sempione
molto famoso forse non qui questo
ritratto di cosimo de medici siamo de
medici ha governato firenze senza
rivestire alcuna carica quindi
semplicemente creando una serie di
alleanze ci sono storici che hanno
parlato di tutta l'attività di medici
dei discorsi possiamo avere moltissime
informazioni sul loro operato però
possiamo anche filtrare queste
informazioni
possiamo andare a vedere per esempio
questa è una mappa delle alleanze delle
famiglie fiorentine del rinascimento
differenti famiglie un legame significa
un matrimonio due membri della famiglia
si sono sposati quindi hanno creato
un'alleanza ora vedete immaginiamo
subito di capire chi è che comanda a
firenze vedendo qual è il vertice quella
famiglia più connessa che è appunto
quella dei medici e vediamo anche che
chi vuole tentare un colpo di stato è
appunto alla periferia vedete i pazzi
sono in basso a sinistra gialli sono una
di queste famiglie isolate dal resto
della rete
e se questo valeva nel rinascimento vale
ancora di più oggi
immaginate di vedere una situazione di
questo tipo potete pensare molte cose
non sembra andare molto d'accordo queste
due persone lui sta al telefono anche
lei sta al telefono non si guardano non
si parlano saranno sui social si stanno
chiamando con altre persone
questo tipo di contatti per la prima
volta si può visualizzare si può
studiare si può misurare allora voi
capite che se lui sta continuamente
mandando messaggi a un'altra persona e
lei fa la stessa cosa abbiamo diciamo
una prova quantitativa che già la foto
ci fa capire forse queste due persone
non vanno molto d'accordo allora abbiamo
una serie enorme di dati abbiamo anche
degli strumenti per la prima volta che
ci consentono di estrarre informazioni
da questi dati
ora la rivoluzione che che noi stiamo
cercando di attuare è quella di
utilizzare queste queste metodologie per
descrivere questo è enorme serie di dati
ma non è una rivoluzione che noi abbiamo
introdotto per la prima volta ci sono
stati altri colleghi io sono un fisico
che hanno studiato situazioni molto
complicate
ora noi i primi esami dell'università ci
fanno studiare tantissime ultime
sappiamo studiare benissimo le
particelle
quindi noi abbiamo questa idea noi ci
vediamo con questa maniera belli che
sappiamo giocare a biliardo sappiamo
calcolare gli urti vinciamo tutto
sommato si dicono pure che siamo un po
spaccone quindi va bene come come
immagine questa e allora se noi sappiamo
questo perché non possiamo descrivere
situazioni come che succede dentro un
bicchiere d'acqua ci sono tante molecole
si urtano io posso calcolare subito che
cosa succede
la probabilità che ha una particella
esca fuori dal bicchiere vada sul tavolo
ecco allora non è esattamente così
questi sono davvero big data qui abbiamo
10 alle 23 10 alle 24 particelle è un
numero sterminato se ognuna di queste
particelle che sono il bicchiere d'acqua
fosse un chicco di riso
io per raccogliere tanti chicchi di riso
quante le molecole che sono lì dentro
dovrei prendere il raccolto in tutto il
mondo che è pari a 739 milioni di
tonnellate e non di un anno non di due
anni ma di 27 milioni di anime per 80
sono immaginato pensateci un attimo a
questo nome
allora c'è un altro modo di fare questa
cosa naturalmente e dei signori nel 1800
che vedete qui hanno provato un altro
approccio detto va bene noi sappiamo gli
urti fra le particelle sappiamo che
possiamo caratterizzare le particelle
per mezzo di una grandezza che la loro
velocità
sappiamo che questa velocità più o meno
in media e ben definita a piccole
variazioni in più o in meno e da qui
riusciamo ad unire il mondo microscopico
quello della velocità della singola
particella con il mondo macroscopico
quello della pressione delle temperature
delle variabili che io riesco a misurare
ora la scienza della complessità vuole
provare a fare la stessa cosa è
possibile utilizzando le nuove
metodologie le nuove tecniche fare
questo allora questa da dove partiamo
questo dove vorremmo arrivare
naturalmente il problema è che le
persone non sono particelle per fortuna
quindi noi siamo caratterizzati da un
numero di variabili ancora sconosciuto
ma sicuramente molto maggiore di 12 in
più noi siamo molto diversi per cui non
abbiamo distribuzione di queste nostre
quantità che fra l'altro neanche
sappiamo bene quali siano caratterizzate
da un valore medio ben chiaro
un po tutti i valori sono possibili ed
in più non abbiamo nessuna idea di quale
sia la relazione che lega il nostro
comportamento microscopico quello della
società però questa è una cosa che ci
piace iniziare a studiare e che vorremmo
fare
e naturalmente per fare questo abbiamo
bisogno di questa matematica di questo
sistema di cui vi ho parlato di questa
teoria delle reti perché perché la
teoria delle reti rende quantitativo una
serie di quantitative una serie di
concetti una serie di grandezze che
prima erano disponibili solo
qualitativamente quanto siamo amici fra
di noi
quanto sono amiche due persone questo
per fortuna non si sarebbe abbastanza
brutto diciamo entrare in questa sfera
emotiva renderla scientifica però però
qualche cosa posso dire per esempio
posso vedere quante mail due persone si
scambiano quante volte una persona
retweet a twitter della prima quante
volte mette like su facebook allora
proprio l'amicizia magari non riesco a
descriverla ma una prossimità riesco a
darle riesco a darmi una misura e riesco
anche a individuare delle comunità di
persone che la pensano più o meno uguale
ma questo è una cosa che posso applicare
a tutto posso applicare una serie di
discipline molto differenti
posso vedere malattie diverse originate
dal malfunzionamento dello stesso gene
se sono simili o no posso vedere
all'interno di una sistema economico
sono per esempio le banche le
istituzioni finanziarie
se una ha un credito e non riesce a
riscuoterlo ma in sofferenza ma allora
anche i creditori della prima vanno in
sofferenza e così via e si può misurare
questa sofferenza possiamo capire quanto
sono simili due prodotti che vengono
prodotti esportati da due nazioni
diverse
qui si può fare tutta una serie di
attività e qui viene la scintilla questa
è la scintilla la scintilla della
complessità è questo nuovo sistema di
metodologie matematiche the idea è che
uniscono discipline che fino allora
erano diverse come come quando due
conduttori si avvicinano e c'è la
scarica e si passa informazione da uno
alla
ora cosa intendo in realtà quali sono
gli ambiti di applicazione beh sono
molteplici oggi bene mostro vene mostro
qualcuno dal dopoguerra dalla seconda
guerra mondiale uno speciale ufficio
delle nazioni unite si occupa di
registrare tutte le merci che vengono
esportate tra le varie nazioni e quindi
noi sappiamo cosa è sporta l'italia che
esporta gli stati uniti così esporta la
cina e partendo da questi dati che sono
dati annuali in dollari e sono si
distingue il chiodo l'arancia il riso il
grano quelle categorie merceologiche e
ben definite
uno potrebbe immaginare che i paesi più
ricchi paesi più avanzati producono le
astronavi i raggi laser tutte queste
cose che associamo alla grande alla
grande tecnologia e i paesi più poveri
ma insomma no fanno prodotti agricoli
fanno i chiodi
in realtà i chiodi migliori li fa la
germania e il giappone in realtà quello
che succede è che i paesi più ricchi
fanno tutto e di più poveri non fanno
quasi niente questo già una prima cosa
inaspettata che viene fuori dall'analisi
dei dati ma si può fare più di così
da questa rete da questo set di
collegamenti fra nazioni io posso vedere
quanto nell'export due nazioni sono
simili e posso anche fare una rete che
mi dice quanto due prodotti sono simili
fra loro e da qui posso fare tutta una
serie di valutazioni quantitative posso
andare nelle banche centrali cosa che
facciamo cosa che alcuni colleghi fanno
di lavoro e aiutarli nei loro stress
test e immaginate una banca centrale
banca d'inghilterra della banca d'italia
deve vigilare sul fatto che il credito
funzioni per tutte le banche del proprio
paese e queste banche sono delle
istituzioni finanziarie che si prestano
dei soldi allora la banca li presta la
banca b la banca b però ha investito in
una cosa che non rende è a rischio
fallimento
e allora anche la banca
diventa a rischio fallimento perché
probabilmente non rivedrà i propri soldi
utilizzando la teoria della complessità
utilizzando questa struttura di rete è
possibile quantificare questo rischio ed
è possibile fare delle previsioni che
insomma mettano sul chi vive le persone
che devono vigilare
quello che si può fare è anche andare a
vedere questo è una figura presa da un
articolo pubblicato alcuni anni fa tutte
quelle malattie che vengono da un
malfunzionamento dei nostri geni o che
comunque diciamo quando come una delle
cause e questo è un particolare gene si
sa è stato visto è stato mostrato può
causare un certo tipo di malattia ma
anche un'altra è chiaro che queste
malattie sono collegate quindi posso
creare una rete e si chiama di
comorbidità dove morbidità non avviene
da morbido ma da morbo quindi la
possibilità la probabilità che una
persona che sviluppa una certa malattia
né sviluppi anche un'altra in futuro e
questo naturalmente come capite è molto
importante ma le applicazioni di questa
teoria della complessità vanno anche al
di là semplicemente dell'analisi
genetica la medicina
allora un sistema molto semplice un
sistema per esempio delle malformazioni
le malocclusione dell'apparato
scheletrico della bocca non hanno solo
una valenza estetica un importanza
estetica anche un'importanza funzionale
clinica
sì insomma si possono essere di disturbi
molto serie e quello che si vede è che
quando nella crescita di un ragazzo di
un
di una persona che sta sviluppando la
dentatura qualcosa comincia andare male
allora va male a gruppi una variabile
che ci denota una malformazione un
angolo troppo piccolo troppo grande
una distanza troppo lunga troppo corta a
porta con sé e poi una variazione anche
gli altri quantità quindi è ancora una
rete anche in questo caso naturalmente
reti internet
la cosa principale a cui uno pensa sono
le reti sociali allora nel mondo sociale
questo è particolarmente chiaro questo
che cos'è questa è una mappa di twitter
una mappa di twitter fatta da un collega
david cavallari s in francia
ogni pallina che vedete lì a un'utenza
di twitter e due utenze sono collegate
se una trita e ritrita
lo stesso messaggio dell'altra da che
cosa si può fare
si può andare a costruire questa mappa
si vede che ci sono dei cluster che
abbiamo colorato che ha colorato davide
in maniera diversa e come ci si può
aspettare da sinistra a destra questo
copre lo schieramento politico francese
quindi si va dalle persone che twittano
su argomenti di di sinistra fino dal
rosso a rosa e chiaro poi si va verso
partiti politici e candidati politici e
twittano riguardo argomenti più di
destra fino ad arrivare fino al penn che
sta al centro di quel cluster marrone
quindi anche gli opinioni politiche
anche le idee vengono caratterizzati in
maniera quantitativa possiamo definire
una distanza e come si fa in francia
possiamo farlo anche in italia questo è
stato fatto da due colleghi ai mt di
luca da fabio e carolina e
anche qui potete vedere la stessa
distanza fra persone ora naturalmente
essendo in italia è un po più
disordinata ma il disordine non non è
mai o non è mai un danno ecco qui questa
erano le cose di cui volevo parlarvi
oggi di questa scienza della complessità
che una scintilla che porta da una
disciplina all'altra c'è un'ultima
metafora che volevo usare volevo dirvi
della scintilla la scintilla è anche
quella che accende il fuoco al fuoco è
qualcosa che scalda qualcosa che
illumina quindi ci permette di
sconfiggere il buio dell'ignoranza e
anche qualcosa che scalda e io questo
spero di aver fatto oggi con voi di
avergli dato un po di calorie devi
guidato un po della passione che io
nello studiare questi argomenti
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]